on this episode we talked to three crazy
snapchatters to learn all about their
lives
this is
Carrie B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 196 I'm
the ask Gary Vee show as you can see we
continue the theme though we did throw
it what was a 195 or was finally mean by
myself here
is that hearing today that's what it's
all [ __ ] confusing the rock which is
travelling with me ever anyway we
continue the theme of having guests on
which I'm enjoying quite a bit and
similar to the influential show where we
talked about YouTube and snapchat things
of that nature
on this episode we have we have three
phenomenally talented individuals that
have different skill sets from being
amazing at sweating to drawing and will
will allow them all a few seconds now to
explain themselves but this is a very
hardcore focus on something we've been
talking about for a couple of years but
intensely for the last six months and
really intensely for the last three
months which is snapchat all these three
lovely massively attractive individuals
are all very influential and deep into
their snapchat universes so so kids why
don't you introduce yourself to the
vaynernation tell them who you are and a
little bit about yourself
let's keep these two 30 40 seconds and
then I'll know we'll expand on these
things but what I want is your name what
you kind of do and then how you kind of
stumbled into the snapchat universe
let's start with the lady respect hi my
name is Amy Q I go on snapchat by
signing Hugh by me saying count oh and I
do snapchat art I draw on snapchat and
tell stories nice aren't as kind of like
an on-the-go special effects and how did
happen to your snapchat journey start it
started off actually with the 11 second
I was an admirer of other people's art
and I created a website and it became a
discovery site and then I grew what did
you build it on pipe I built it
it was first was a Tumblr Instagram was
in a tumbler it was it was a blogger and
then after
migrated into a wordpress so yeah it's
updated site right now but basically
that's how I started and like the
community grew and then we started to
helping each other grow it's amazing
really nice and you're from where I'm
from Arkansas Blue Rock Arkansas love
that I'm a man
I've name's Mike Plateau go by em flacco
on snapchat Lakes Irene artist
storyteller I found that snap type just
like everyone else did just because
people were talking about it started
making these insanely intricate drawings
of myself as Harry Potter had a bunch of
them on tumblr went viral started
getting calls from brands so that's my
career it's amazing and were you from
Austin Austin are you patriots man no
great that was huge that made me very
happy
the man you're you're you're sweating
already my meeting with this guy huge
mistake
yeah billion dollar mistake my name is
Taylor Nick like Taylor dot Nicolai on
snapchat aha dot for emphasis
uh there was a girl who took Taylor
Nikolai before I could and I offered to
buy from her and she blocked me on
snapchat how much did you offer I have
four five hundred dollars like a year
ago solid numbers like a anyway I'm
Taylor Nikolai you pronounce my name
Nikolai in the song is ni ke ola I
that's how you spell Nikolai I'm really
awkward and that's why people like me I
guess I love it
you can sing do you think my name is
missing my name to try to spell mater
Chuck right now vay and ER CH UK oh you
got it no space cool get that clip I
want that to be my ring all right so one
from Minnesota yes Vikings fan I love
that I know the owners of the Vikings
quite well they're from Springfield New
Jersey where wine library's from where
my career started you want to get me
some tickets
sure do you want them to be good yes
okay done so gang I think we're gonna
answer some questions India you're here
too and you also draw on snapchat you do
sorry I could see nothing I don't watch
anybody stories I really turn I'm the
worst and so will you now up your
drawing game have you been motivated by
the first 40 seconds of the show Oh Nick
show this this is amazing dear I please
show what's happening here
Nick once you tell everybody who you are
which makes what you're doing right now
way more fun for everybody
these three guys to the show yes oh yeah
let's let's get into this show okay
great
let's do it awesome Matteo but doesn't
mind Mike pick stuff up yeah
if so the sound will be not as good for
a second do you have one because you
like one me so up there you'll see I
grew up in the wine business yes I got
it following along I never I don't like
assuming people know stuff you know I
think it's a douche exactly I should be
posting so I actually have like seven
million dollars amazing friends
withdrawing yes like I was the guy first
posit is fine son it's about the
Internet that's amazing yeah that's
really cool you have it under in your
account or across a bunch of different
sites
Oh funny 33 different yes
can we go I have a client meeting we're
good all right now let's get into this
hey Gary I'm Mateo from Italy amazing
country super girl super food but the
highest rate of gambling addiction I
open a profit that operates in the space
and I would like to hear from you on
this point as a marketer how to involve
our members to spread the no gambling
cause so to reach more and more people
thanks a lot you rock and so how do we
how do we mateo wants me to help him do
a marketing campaign to stop people from
gambling because he thinks gambling's
ruling italy because the food and the
girls part is fine but the gambling is a
problem and so he wants to create a
marketing campaign to stop gambling well
I mean look I think any cause regardless
of what you know by the way I like
gambling but you know any causes
expansion has to do with the right
creative in the right medium to me if
he's got a lot of passion to stop the
gambling cause there's a very smart
strategy tying in what we're doing here
to go younger usually the thing that you
need to do to stop a movement is to go
younger it's really no different than
Facebook and snapchat even like the
generational differences so the way you
get you know people to stop using drugs
or drinking and driving and all the
things that have happened in propaganda
in the u.s. to stop things that people
were concerned about was you've got to
win the youth culture around that
subject matter and then let it mature so
I think Matteo and and the people in
Italy that want to stop the kind of
gambling culture in that country should
be looking more aggressively towards
snapchat and Instagram new platforms
that are doing extremely well in their
country anything to add youngsters I
know that's kind of
left ball field question I'm not sure
where India was going with that strategy
see that made sense to me
thanks for ruining the show let's go
next question what's up Gary my name is
Aaron Martinez and I hope you like the
Hat but my question for you is I have a
YouTube channel that has grown from 0 to
88 thousand subscribers and a little bit
under 10 months now on the channel I
upload snapchat tips and tricks but I
try to do a little bit of other things
and the earlier stages in my channel but
they didn't really work out going into
the future of my channel maybe passing a
hundred thousand subscribers what do you
think I should do primarily stick to
snapchat or try to do different things
and if so what thanks guys over at
vaynermedia hope you guys have a nice
day
iron I think and I'll let these guys
jump in cuz I'm sure they have a lot to
add to this I mean but unlike the first
question you know Aaron I think a couple
things that struck me with that question
number one this magical number of like a
hundred thousand followers of your first
thousand or a million I'm telling you
and I'm telling this because I have a
lot of hard for the youngster sitting
with me right now these are the wrong
metrics to reverse engineer against more
importantly what I would need if you
were here what I would need to know and
we were just talking for a second as the
rock broke the sound is you know what do
you want to happen so you know I think
one of the biggest mistakes by so many
snapchat and YouTube influencers right
now is they want to become Hollywood
famous because they grew up where that
was the pinnacle and to me I keep trying
to remind them my early days with Jerome
and Rudy and Britney for a lot and that
whole space with the vine influencers
that we're definitely the spark that
you've watched the Instagram and
snapchat thing very different than
generation of YouTube that I grew up
with is guys in 20 22 and 20 24 the most
famous person is not the person that's
on a TV show on MTV it's the person that
dominates this which is the new
television just like being a cable star
wasn't interesting in the early 80s but
then eventually if you're the number one
star on an HBO show which to remind
everybody you guys are too young for
this HP was [ __ ] HBO was a [ __ ] place to
go in 1982 and 1984 1986 you were a BC
List d-list efflux nobody wanted to be a
Netflix star forty-eight one
ago nobody now everybody wants to in
Hollywood so first and foremost Aaron I
think that you need to decide what you
want to happen do you want to get your
art into the world is it about money is
it about Fame and I think you need to
own your vanity because way too many
people try to [ __ ] it number one
number two you've got to go word the
attention is to me enormous emphasis on
snapchat and YouTube and now look one
minute Instagram videos probably opens
up a lot of creativity for a lot of
people here and definitely people that
are watching so that becomes a new thing
and look musically actually it's a
question from you real quick are any of
the three of you playing on musically
yeah after you talk about it a couple
times have you kind of had the time yet
to spend to look at what's going on
there yeah and so this is what's so
interesting right a lot of my youtube
celebrity friends when vine came along
were like yeah and I'm like and I'm like
you you came from YouTube that's what
was just being said five minutes ago now
then a lot of fun snapchat came I was
selling a lot of Viners I'm like this
thing I'm telling you and I'm like yeah
and then of course now everybody's there
and now even musically right like
snapchat as it's a its apex but
ironically I think the snapchatters and
if I'm giving you advice right now that
go and really go all in on musically
they're gonna win those junior high
people are gonna be here in 36 months
and be like holy [ __ ] that was a good
idea or it could go away but much like
what happened on vine and this is such a
good learning from vine and we were
talking about vying off as the rock
broke the sound and you know the people
that won on vine have been able to
siphon that attention and be successful
in other platforms not everybody and it
exactly not everybody because some of
them wouldn't have held on vine either
because they didn't have enough talent
to be anything more than a few minutes
but some were and that's no different
than being a really good actor on a hit
show on CBS for two seasons and then
coming back two years later on ABC and
siphoning some of that audience and
building on that momentum these are
channels and doing the right thing so
Aaron I think I think what you need to
do is this and I would say this for the
three individuals here who have a lot of
hard for 80% tripling down on what works
you guys can [ __ ] draw you're funny
and intriguing all that stuff can't draw
I cannot draw as what answer but you
want to learn maybe someday
never yeah correct so 80% of that and
20% experimenting that's what you should
be doing Aaron from my point of view
yang can I say something
yes nobody cares about subscribers
nobody cares about followers it's all
about influence if you can actually
create a sustainable amount of influence
or like something that you can actually
push to other platforms that's something
people care about numbers is not
something people are going to care about
in the future a hundred thousand
subscribers or a million subscribers if
nobody's consistently watching your
videos nobody cares I agree with that
I mean look brands brands care now cuz
they're not sophisticated in their
language right well three years well it
depends right like so the answer the
answer is look results should and always
do matter at the end there's a lot of
things that can be a metric can be
accepted by a marketplace like Nielsen
ratings that doesn't map to a result yet
the entire eighty billion dollar
advertising industry most of it doesn't
quantify against actual results they
quantify against metrics I'm with you
and by the way all my behavior maps to
your rant right so that's what I'm
living but no question matters in
general are broken they're the whole
industry is broken on metrics yeah I
mean the metric that should matter is
how many did you sell of whatever that
is and what I mean sell it's like look
you know I want you to donate to my
nonprofit like that's a result or you
did a show and how many people showed up
to it to like watching paint for an hour
India and so and so uh I think I think
that's the case and any thoughts on
Aaron's questions um it's funny we've
all actually know Aaron no and he no
he's great he does some yeah it was like
snapchat tutorials dipped into his
YouTube but um absolutely that's
something that we need to expand upon
because he's got to identify what it is
that he wants to be not just someone
with a hundred thousand subscribers on
YouTube whatever he wants to turn this
career into and then play to that yeah
Aaron I think you've clearly got some
chops and I think the question becomes
what what do you at this young and by
the way for all three of you what do you
at this young of an age want to happen
and then try to project who you think
you are in the balance of vanity money
happiness you
work-life balance these are a lot of
things you have to project at a young
age that yeah I mean right and and by
the way everybody's got different
percentages of it to minutes and and
that's that
let's move I've got this client thing we
broke sound we relate [ __ ] people
running and yoga you what's up it's been
from Israel I'm a professional snapchat
artist and a youtuber and I have one
very important question to ask you in a
country that is known as the startup
nation there's one problem one ironic
problem as much as we're innovative the
problem is we suck in social media
marketing now people here just don't get
it that what we do the creators on
social media such as snapchat and
YouTube are doing the correct thing but
they don't give us a lot of room to work
they don't pay us to get our job done
the thing is people like us want to
leave from something we love and we know
how to talk to the right audience now
how can we convince the mainstream media
that what we do is the right thing how
can we convince someone so big as the
mainstream media to change the ways and
give us the underdog the chance to
create something amazing to do something
that really counts thanks man appreciate
it and love you work what's his name
Ben what do you have for Ben well like
what you said I mean everything's
converting this is the new TV and so if
the mainstream media is still thinking
about like the old style they're going
to miss out on the new audience that's
becoming of this and I think that I mean
like there's not much convincing they
can just look at the numbers they can
look at all the people that are on
snapchat right now less people are
watching TV I'm not watching TV anymore
if you ask all the other people they're
on YouTube they're on snapchat and it's
it's becoming you know just outdated
absolutely go to where the audiences are
and if you have something compelling to
say say it make that content it doesn't
matter if but how do you how do we
answer his question which is how how do
you think you know agreed we're all
gonna wrong in a head nod
what about convincing these individuals
to do it
you're in a tough spot right because
it's coming to you right now right yeah
like when when the inbound traffic's
coming to you and saying hey can you
draw this for my brand you're not
worried about commencing because you
don't have to I mean like first off who
cares what the mainstream media thinks
like just do what you're going to do
anyway and be consistent about it and
then like success will eventually come
if you're talented outside of that like
how do you get what you deserve to be
paid well you're going to get what you
deserve to be paid and if you're not
getting what you deserve to be paid then
ask for what you deserve to be paid or
and I agree very honestly like I I
wasn't like super that was a great
question but like like tough [ __ ] like
like like my whole life has been
predicated on selling something that is
ahead of the market you have to wait the
answer is the markets gonna pay you for
what it think it's worth like people
like us here's a couple of things that
I'm gonna pick and I love you
I mean thank you for the kind words but
people like us want to get paid for
something we want to create so does
everybody like everybody wants to be
able to get paid to do what they loved
every single athlete that grows up from
6 to 14 years old would like to be paid
to be a professional athlete you know
another thing that I liked is omits and
I've heard this from this sector
including you guys I'm a professional
YouTube and snapchat but what does that
mean like do we just get to say we're
professionals like it sounds like if
you're gonna be a professional like
these get into semantics I've talked
about lot about this on the show like
you can call it whatever you like we can
call whatever you want but to me being a
professional means that you actually do
it for a living and so a lot to many
people like I'm that without being able
to do it for a living this is what your
platform is trying to solve so look
here's what I would say you know tough
[ __ ] you live in Israel tough [ __ ]
they're not spending as much money tough
you know the other thing is you've got
to prove it one thing that a lot of
influencers are not proving is yeah
you're talking to the right listen if
you're selling insurance the 40 to 60
year olds or do you have that you have
the audacity to tell them that they
should be on snapchat to sell what
you're gonna say if you really get put
into a corners no I don't know I think
it went you know it's so funny I love
watching everybody's everybody under
t7 is right and so you're selling to 27
and unders in the US then snapchat and
Instagram becomes very compelling if
you're selling retirement home space
like snapchats probably not the right
platform today I do think snapchat much
like Facebook will age up in a way that
most people don't believe I do believe
that in 24 months most 55 year-old men
are on snapchat and I think that
confuses people we'll see what's on the
record what about to find out what
happens is is that it either happens or
it doesn't and here's the more
interesting part whether or not it
happens at all
sooner than two years in two years is
kind of irrelevant because whatever does
happen is what you have to act around
and so I would tell you that there's
plenty of people making money off of
snapchat and YouTube you have to go and
grab it to your point and more
importantly if you don't then maybe
you're not a good salesperson and maybe
you're just a creative and you actually
need a sales partner there's that part
of it because the creative world and the
business world are very often at odds
there are few that cross and have boat
skills and Mom and Dad had sex at the
right moment and gave them those talents
but a lot of people don't and that's
something else that we have to factor in
India that's it for those two got it all
right well do you guys have any
questions yeah actually um so obviously
you're someone who has an intimate
knowledge of how vine stars came to be
and which ones took the right steps and
didn't so much someone likes I mean like
myself storytelling drawing yes on
snapchat a platform that's you know it's
vertical where do you think a logical
next step would be if we want to
continue making content like we're
making knowing that snapchat can't just
be the only thing that we wrong well
look I mean I think you know I think
there's a several different things in
play here number one first and foremost
I really recommend to you and this genre
I would love for you guys to make the
physical manifestation of these products
at scale like I think one of the great
opportunities for you guys this is this
is not answering your question I think I
just want to get this in the show before
I forget I I truly believe that both of
you have the ability to make millions of
dollars a year in prints of your
drawings if you figure out that
connection
oh boy and you need to think about that
that is like a real-life thing that you
need to figure out tomorrow I'm sure you
are but I mean like I think you have the
ability to take a snap that you draw on
top up and have 41,000 people buy that
$19 poster at scale I think it's a real
business for the artists of snapchat so
that's that's random as far as your
question which is if snapchat was to
only have a 24 month more run because
something came along like you know I
think I think you have to understand I
know I think you have to understand that
um that uh that your art is your skill
set and so it's funny on snapchat right
now that's peaking very aggressively for
Taylor his his skill translates to every
medium your advantage because there's
drawing capabilities on top is different
it is unique to that platform and that
is something you have to think about
it's and you have to think about what
does that actually mean and and I would
say that yours doesn't naturally
transpose into everywhere else because
it stands out I mean I still can't wrap
my head around that picture you drew
like so crazy but I don't think if you
drew it on a piece of paper or if that
was on a post on tumblr that I would
react the same way and so that's just
truth and that's just the reality and
guess what that's just life right like
the people that were amazing at radio
because they had amazing voices and they
were comfortable to be in a booth and
then it went to television and they were
scared of the camera they lost and so
that's something to think about that
just real doesn't necessarily transpose
listen you guys heard the knocks
unfortunately he was late and he broke
sound and so we're gonna have to wrap up
the show I apologize guys but I have to
go actually you know what look you
something interesting don't you guys
talk for five minutes and wrap up the
show in the rock do your thing I'm out
they're gonna finish and we'll see you
soon
love you guys first time it's rare do
you think figure it out everyone who's
watching who's in the veer nation and
still think snapchat is a terrible
investment of their time what would you
say to them just very easy like very
simple question you can't I mean
something that is there so many people
using it it's not a waste of time
it's a beautiful app that is just as
conducive to absorbing content as
creating content so my big mission
to get people to go out and make things
and snapchat is the perfect segue into
that so for that reason alone you should
go out and and and and learn about
making things it's incredibly satisfying
for me
download snapchat get on it and start
doing cool stuff why would it be a waste
of time it's like billions of followers
are on it um and that's that's a
platform that you know has influencers
has creators and that can like put a
message out in in 24 hours to like
thousands of people I don't think that's
a waste of time there's certainly no
other platform that commands your
attention like snapchat yes if you're in
marketing or social media and you're
still not sure about snapchat you're
stupid and you should quit your job and
never work in marketing or social media
ever again so like that the fact that a
man asked that question signifies that
you are in the wrong industry so you
were just you didn't actually we should
talk about like discovery on snapchat
maybe snapchat will like listen to us
what use our discovery yeah you don't
have a sorry if I can ask you because
how did you start to grow on snapchat
how did there's no discovery platform
there's basically it's you have to take
your audience outside of snapchat I
basically like screenshotted your
snapchat put you on the website you
became friends with me and you shouted
me out I shouted you out I became
friends with other people and it's
basically creating this community that
help each other grow but we need
something to grow more than that
community people are creating you create
awesome content Taylor creates awesome
jokes okay like never mind don't follow
and like there's so much in like in it
snapchat has this Discovery Channel with
awesome content but they're not
supporting you know like this raw
content that that creators from
everywhere are creating and if they want
to be like this new social media
platform that has you know the news the
the the content I mean they have to
start supporting the creators and not
just the the paid brands the repurposed
content from other web sites yeah like
I've told you I don't want a Discovery
option I think that the would lead to
too quick of saturation and what happens
so often when there is a Discovery
option like what we saw in vine is that
the the little pretty teenage boys just
show off in the skyrocket to the top no
I like I think over saturation is is
such an easy thing to happen like
thousands of stuff but you only have a
few ones people are going to be more
selective but if you'll be more you'll
discover page that's different than a
popular page I would say an editorial
discovery page would be something that I
wouldn't support but anything that's
like popular on snapchat is super gross
to me I think would be interesting to
see what would happen
given that the platform is so
established right now introducing it
this late in the game it would be a
really a game changer in I mean vine it
started out with that to get a popular
page like whoa yeah and I mean just the
ability to the search ability yeah and
and sharing and having any sort of
metrics tied to your content
yeah like loops just came one question I
have for you guys is when do you think
snapchat will show views to public so
like we know how many views we get but
when do you think snapchat will show the
public how many views
I'm keeping the public the views private
it's actually like less social like for
people who are not influencing they
don't want to show their views to the
public because so do not think that
they'll show views to public I don't
think they should because it's like you
know there's billions of people
following it maybe like a hundred
I don't know influencers and like we
want to show our view to the public but
other people don't want to show that
they only have like 17 views or 17 of
their friends do it so yeah Chad
influencers with like 17 people watching
that's that's that's a problem yeah but
you know it's you have to like think
about how other people are using it to I
mean like there's the influencer part
and there's the other part I mean like
what do you what do you do with the
other billion of people that doesn't
want to show their views and doesn't
wanna be like Facebook that because it's
like snapchat is popular because you
can't see the likes you can't see the
views and people can just post freely
and that's why that's what's so
attractive on snapchat if you take that
away and you know cater fully the
influencers then it's gonna lose its
magic it's gonna become the Facebook
yeah I don't think it will ever I don't
think they will ever make that
information public really but some of
that we care about but nobody else
really cares about yeah you just look at
what happened with your score score was
something that used to be very visible
you didn't have to follow someone or
have them follow you back to see their
snapchat score which is how many snaps
you've received and opened in addition
to how many snaps individual snaps you
have sent but and now that has something
that has even become more restricted in
how you can view that person you have to
follow them and they have to follow you
back for you to be able to see their
snapchat scores so given that
information alone that they're already
starting to withhold some of that some
of those metrics I don't think they
would ever come out and make views and
screenshots something that everyone
could say so like I guess are we
watching snapchat kind of evolve mainly
into just back to a messaging messaging
platform again I think it always was a
messaging platform that was their main
goal and certainly with the chat 2.0
upgrade which really seamless and helped
me I mean it's a really good update you
really I think that they're solidifying
their place as a competitor to facebook
Messenger and
was the whatsapp yeah so like here's a
crazy question do you think that we
would ever see them take away Stuart no
this is the only thing that makes it a
viable option for brands you don't see
brands doing anything effective on
WeChat or facebook Messenger yeah those
purely messaging apps aren't a territory
that brands have a viable play in at
least right now and anything that I've
seen so I mean stories is what may
discover possible what made any sort of
publishing possible obviously we
survived all the stories but yeah
absolutely you wanted to you know send
snap to every single person which back
in the day that's exactly what we would
do and learning that you know and send
it 200 people at a time mblaq goes oh
gee by the way oh gee okay i got it
right no okay well do you have another
question or Oh usually on the show we do
a question of the day for the community
and everybody answers it in the comments
on Facebook and YouTube
so maybe each of you could ask a
question of the day I want three CY re
and so first question that there are two
types of content on snapchat there's the
kind that's highly refined with music
and filters and very much a storytelling
piece of content and then there's the
day to day the stuff that Gary does and
what I'm wondering is how the general
public feels about that highly refined
almost outside of the scope of what
snapchat was intended for type of
content is that something that you like
or is the the more live-streaming you
know no second chance just take it post
it is that more something that you enjoy
what kind of content do you like better
so that I can do it
what your other question I can't title
that okay
have you ever unfollowed someone on
snapchat
if so why I don't follow DJ Khaled I got
bored I can only watch him with his
flowers so many times whoa bless up
really long and know it autoplay so you
really unfollow him okay so what you do
yes okay maybe that's what you need
refine content you need everyday content
there's not choosing both you need just
mix it up or else you can get unfollowed
there's the answer would be question
well Mike what I was gonna ask Gary but
we didn't have time was what do you
think will be the first social media
platform in terms of like what it will
entail on VR that that's what I'm very
curious about right now because it's any
day now we there will be that first
platform and everybody's going to get on
it day one and that's going to be all
the future celebrities are going to be
VR celebrities and it's like who's going
to be that I always think like five
years down the road well I can tell you
if you're gonna ask Gary that question
you would probably be able to find the
answer and whether or not he's investing
in VR platforms but I certainly don't
think that it's anywhere near there
might be something that pops up I don't
think there's anything that's gonna
really have traction for at least five
years how do you find people to follow
they're not your friends on snapchat I
go to the 11th second dot-com yes props
for cyrene she's done more for the
snapchat community of artists and
storytellers and influencers than
anybody 11 second comm really it was the
discover section in snapchat that was
non-existent and it's an amazing
platform where you should go and look at
all fantastic
snapchat I want to show you that the
picture that you drew Gary alone
hey it's scary Vaynerchuk
it look like them no it's absolutely
MBLAQ oh they look like each other
it only looks exactly like it I'm sorry